[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Star Trek Picard Episode
one video hopefully you've had a chance
to see the episode if you're brand new
to my channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the easter-egg videos there are
a whole bunch of callbacks and
references to the other Star Trek series
most notably Star Trek The Next
Generation in the next generation movies
so we'll break all that down as I go
through my top 10 WTF but careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet obviously starting with
number 10 though welcome back the card
in data so they start on 10 Ford on the
enterprise you're in the future but
you're basically inside the car it's
mine space he's having a nightmare about
what happened to Marg that they talk
about later in the episode there was a
big question about why he would ever
leave Starfleet so I'll address that in
my list here because it's a pretty big
WTF moment but this is all taking place
about 20 years after the end of Star
Trek nemesis don't worry you don't have
to rewatch that movie they also sort of
retcons some of the elements of the
ending of Star Trek nemesis so if you
hated that movie they're actually kind
of wiping it a little bit from the
timeline just a little bit although
technically those events still did
happen like data did die at the end of
Star Trek nemesis they're playing poker
just like they did during Star Trek next
generation data trying to bluff him they
have a couple jokes about data being bad
at trying to bluff then Picard gets a
bit of a call to action there are a
couple lines of dialogue they give him
calls to action throughout the episode
but it's not till way later at the end
of the episode before he gets the
literal wake-up call that calls him to
action to help find out what happened to
quote-unquote
the girl he wakes up from his nightmare
we find that he's been living on his
family's vineyard in France Chateau
Picard you see Chateau Picard show up
all over the place they're even drinking
wine in the big scene after this - but
he has a dog he's named number one which
is a Riker reference Riker comes back I
think in the next episode in seven of
nine they're a bunch of familiar
characters from the other Star Trek
series that are showing up
number nine WTF the activation so you go
to Boston you meet the new main
character or one half of the main
character because she's a twin that we
learned later in the episode they
referenced the daystrom Institute she's
a specialist in artificial intelligence
and quantum consciousness that should be
the Day Giveaway that's like saying that
she's an expert in data basically so
there should have been a bit of a lead
off that she's connected to data somehow
we learned that it's a Romulan strike
that's after her so they crash in they
kill him and try to take her before she
can quote-unquote activate then we find
out what that means when they put the
bag over her head and she just goes into
action just wasting all of em in no time
at all she still doesn't understand
what's going on
she's flesh and blood like a human would
be but she has this weird vision of
Picard
so she eventually starts to track him
down then number eight the brand new
intro sequence so you noticed that
there's no intro narration from Picard
like they did during Star Trek next
generation I was a little bummed out by
that but I guess that's what they're
doing with all the new Trek shows no
opening narration it starts with a shard
of glass cracking away from the sky like
the reality is cracking or it's fake
it's a holodeck projection and we follow
the shard as it falls through layers of
reality or layers of memory because
we're talking about spinning out a new
consciousness and rebuilding data's
neural net it starts with Picard's
vineyard because he's the main character
of the series then as it travels through
that layer of reality you start to see
these little like memory engrams as it
travels through the Borg cube we see
that later in the episode because that's
where her twin is working it's the Borg
cube that the Federation in the galaxy
has co-opted to use for the Romulan
people this pattern evolving here is
what's talked about later when they're
at the daystrom Institute Alison pihl's
character basically explains that they
can rebuild data so to speak or rebuilt
his technology using a single neuron
that's basically what you're watching
here the process of that happening it
evolves but it turns into Picard just
because he's the main character the
series but we're also probably
witnessing the act of creation of the
twin girls to when they were first
created which they do explain during the
episode they play a couple notes from
the Star Trek next generation theme song
at the end of this but it is a brand-new
song for the most part the number seven
the backstory and the crossover moments
with the 2009 Star Trek movie from the
Kelvin timeline so the big thing here
you probably notice is that they're
connecting this to the JJ Abrams new
Star Trek movies through the really big
act that destroys Romulus the big
supernova if you're confused about what
Picard did that forced him or made him
want to leave Starfleet he was actually
trying to help save the Romulan people
but at some point during that process
the Federation decided that they didn't
want to help the Romulans because
they've been their enemies for so long
Picard revolted he refused to leave the
area without rescuing the Romulan so
that was already a big act of
insubordination again
Starfleet but while that was going on
they say that a rogue group of
synthetics took advantage of the chaos
and wiped out the Utopia Planitia
shipyards near Mars killing about 90,000
people because of that catastrophe there
was a federation and a galaxy-wide ban
on synthetics so right now the Romulans
aren't the most hated people in the
galaxy it's actually synthetic people
which kind of makes this new girl
character or the surviving twin a baby
Yoda so to speak so they're kind of
going for a baby Yoda vibe she has to be
protected because everyone wants a piece
of her either to kill her like the
Romulans or to exploit her like some of
the researchers probably want to do so
after all that happens Picard is just
really upset with the decisions that the
Federation is making he decides to
resign his commission and goes to live
on his vineyard the number-6 a little
wild goes by the girl finds Picard he's
not totally sure what's going on but she
seems kind of familiar to him she thinks
that she knows him but she doesn't know
how just because it seems like all of
her programming is subconscious and it
requires really heightened stress levels
to activate it later Picard has a dream
where he sees data underneath a tree in
his classic next-gen uniform Picard
himself in his classic next-gen uniform
he's painting the picture of the girl
that's hanging in a study and later in
the archives of the girl herself data
asks if he wishes to finish it this is
another one of those call-to-actions
Picard's like I don't know how and data
says no that's not true
you totally know how to do this it's
basically Picard telling himself that he
does have the ability to take this
mission on and save this girl so number
5 WTF the big one Picard discovers the
girl's true identity is data's daughter
in effect obviously not biological
daughter but the way she's created she's
created from one of datas neurons so she
is in effect data's daughter there's all
kinds of Easter eggs when he goes into
the archives they have a funny joke
about the hologram trying to tell a joke
we're trying something new don't quit
your day job there's a model of the
enterprise
Efram the next-gen movies this was last
seen during Star Trek nemesis don't
worry we don't have to speak of that
movie ever again there's some of his
books his commendations things that were
hanging inside his ready room there's
one of wharfs bat'leth they even put the
banner from the Picard Day episode in
there too and it's all signed by the
kids that he had the adventure with
during that episode they made very clear
to show you the name
those little kids just referencing the
events of that episode he pulls the
painting out and it's not really clear
why this is the original or if the other
ones a copy or what's going on to the
really advanced version of Alexa tells
him no this was given to you as painted
by Commander data over 30 years ago
the paintings title was daughter later
when the girl flees into the street and
calls her mother worried about what to
do and she tells her about Picard wait a
minute I didn't mention Picard it's
pretty clear that the mother is
connected to the maddox figure from the
daystrom Institute and knows exactly
what's going on
go find Picard he'll take care of you so
keep in mind that none of these people
her mother her father that she keeps
referring to and her sister also refers
to our Father made these necklaces for
us those aren't their biological parents
obviously she has no biological parents
or if you want to think about it that
way data would be her biological father
she tracks Picard down at Starfleet
headquarters how did you find me here
you're not even supposed to be able to
track me without a security clearance
which you definitely don't have so she
comes to the realization of who she
really is then completely hooks out on
the Romulan assassins it's a really good
action scene pretty good fight scene but
even though I knew that this actress was
going to be a main character this season
I wasn't totally sure how they were
going to explain her coming back by the
end of the episode I totally was not
expecting her to be a twin so that's the
way they're keeping the character around
on the show although you know talk about
twins data's twin brother lore it's two
twin girls so instead of data and lore
it's now these two twin sisters except
one of them just died it's not totally
clear why the Romulan assassins want her
dead they think that she's going to do
something terrible presumably but you do
notice that when she gets some of their
green blood on her its corrosive it
starts burning through her like acid she
screams in pain so one of the big
differences in the fact that she's a
flesh and blood Android is that she can
feel pain whereas data could not but if
it wasn't clear based on the ending of
the episode and what happens after this
I'm pretty sure that she died in this
explosion so she's not around but her
twin sister is still alive number three
WTF he goes to the daystrom Institute
and finds out the truth about data's
twin daughters where they came from and
how they were created
Alison pihl's character is also a main
character on the show so she'll be
traveling around with Picard later
episodes her name is dr. jarate she
explains that her partner basically
the twin girls based on a fractal
cloning idea like oh you can take one
little neuron and clone the original
creation but it winds up turning into
his daughters and they're always created
in pairs twins just like data and lore
we haven't met the Maddox figure I'm
assuming he'll show up later in the
series but her former partner that went
into hiding and then created the twins
is basically the person that the girls
keep referring to as their father really
fun callback to a really bad movie when
they referenced Star Trek nemesis by
inking out B 4 from storage the big red
car to that though is that that didn't
work they say all that stuff was lost
all of datas memories and he wound up
being this inferior version of data so
this is them saying that they're not
going to be pursuing B for as the future
of the data character it's gonna be
through his daughters number 2 this is
actually really cool reveal the Romulan
reclamation site the place where they
took the Romulan people after they saved
them they're about 900 million plus
Romulans that they save from destruction
are all living on a giant Borg cube
I love the visual way they reveal this
to like first you just think it's a
really big Space Station oh wow this
seems kind of ominous but you know
pretty cool love big Space Station's but
as it slowly pans out at the end of the
episode you find out what's really going
on wait a minute where did this Borg
cube come from is that somehow the
spoils of war how are they using it
without the Borg technology over running
them what's going on with all the Borg
nanites there are some Borg that are
working within Starfleet or at least
friendly to Starfleet like seven of nine
does it look like she's Starfleet
anymore but she's one of the main
characters on the series but Hugh from
Star Trek The Next Generation the other
Borg character is back so maybe he and
other Borg like him that have turned
good are trying to help the Federation
use this Borg technology the number one
WTF we get the big reveal of the twin
and we find out she's just called dr.
Shoji she's working there as a medical
doctor the person that comes to talk to
her narak just seems like he's a Vulcan
because narak seems like a Vulcan name
it's kind of hard to tell Romulans from
Vulcans unless you know what their name
is or know how they act it felt like a
pretty strong premier at least the
premise I'm really interested to see
where they take this series so let me
know what you guys thought of it if you
spotted any big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna see how this
video performs if enough people like the
series and watch this video I'll keep
doing episode
videos but otherwise at least do a
wrap-up video when it's all done
there'll be 10 episodes total everyone
click here for my brand new Avengers
evil Captain America teaser video and
click here from a new Star Wars Clone
Wars season 7 trailer with baby Yoda and
Mandalorian Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I have spoken
[Music]
you